so you can see this is not just like
some fancy oh okay that's a nice thing
we're not in triangles anymore it's
actually the whole way we get this graph
because I just think about down here not
even ya know figure out down here right
do you see these angles
what are these angles by the way you
pass your um what's this 180 degrees all
the way up to we should put those on
those angles carne exists in triangles
right but they can exist in circles
that's where we get them from okay so
let's go ahead and put those on 180
degrees and you'll also tell me 361 of
those in radians the middle ones pi and
then the last one is 2pi very good
[Music]
there's one point missing with is sort
of like we've skipped over it just in
the middle there what's the missing
value for X anyway it's 270 degrees or
3pi on two very good and what's its
corresponding Y value it'll be negative
one you can see it down the bottom and
as mrs. Lee's pointed out if we came
back to our unit circle right sine is
the y-coordinate so here I am starting
in the positive x-axis let's go around
90 degrees 180 degrees he's 270 and
what's the y-coordinate there's my
negative one okay so let's go ahead and
put that on okay are you happy with that
important things to note this shape here
that you can see this sort of archway
looking thing it's not a semicircle it's
not a semicircle like this that's not a
sine curve and it's also gentle and
curved it's not pointy and sharp like
that these are sort of caricatures of
what no one's graph is going to look
quite exactly this bad but people get
close to that and it make is really
important to make sure we don't see
those very common errors okay this first
one we should label it is y equals sine
X and we have drawn it a certain set of
X values what do you call that by the
way certain set of X values we didn't
draw it forever we restricted it what's
that called the set of X values starts
with a D it's the domain right what's
the domain for this half five we drawn
it
from domains met x-values right
horizontally so this is starting from
zero all the way up to 360 or we could
have said to two pi okay in fact I'm
going to write both of them zero degrees
to 360 this of course is a pretty
standard domain to graph in but you
won't always graph it like that in fact
when you that's not a degree sign when
you get to the exercise shortly one of
the main things that they point out is
hey can you also draw these elsewhere
can you draw them from negative pi to pi
that's a very common one or from
negative 2 pi all the way to 2 pi so
it's a copy of that this is the essence
of what we're going to get everything
out of can I get you from sign to
centering cosign without my Oh mrs.
vases help maybe some of you have
already started doing that which is
great for the rest of you have a go and
make sure it's the same size put on
these same kinds of features you don't
have to label everything we did before
but I want to make sure I know where
everything is if you think you're super
advanced and mrs. Leeson I've given you
a thumbs up go on to tan as well that
would be great things are mostly looking
good with a few bits of fine tuning I
was about to do the one for cause and
then just talk to you through it but
then I thought you know actually what
might help a lot of you is just to see
the way in which I construct it because
that's half of the job right the sine
graph we're saying to these guys before
it's both in achievement that I'm proud
of and not proud of but I've literally
drawn hundreds of thousands of these
over my life so I'm pretty good and just
eyeballing that one of the things which
I noticed a lot of people have struggled
to do especially if you tried to do this
is pick up a ruler and then have a look
at the distance for example from on your
arm on your page from 0 to 180 and then
from 180 to 360 now because I'm so
unashamedly brilliant at graphing mind
literally bang on 20 centimeters each
time that's actually that's actually
mostly luck
the next the next 10 graphs I do will
not be that good but I know for a fact
I'm not as good at doing that as I am at
doing the cosine graph I just
I haven't done it as often right so when
I do the curse time guys please look
closely right and I'll show you the
order in which I did this firstly you
know how I went 0 90 180 270 360 and we
did it in radians as well I mark out
these for the cosine graph and for the
tan graph because I know they're always
going to be important and I also know
where they're supposed to be so they're
very helpful kind of anchors for me when
I then have a look further once I've got
those horizontal PI on 2 pi 3 PI over 2
to PI once I've got them in I then say
what's the cosine graph supposed to do
why is it called cosine can anyone tell
me what's the KO is also an abbreviation
and no it abbreviates honey yeah very
good so the co here is short for
complement complement with an e not come
from with an eye not like nice anti
shiny even though it wasn't nice answer
this is adds up to 90 degrees right
that's what a complement is and so the
effect on the graph is that you shift
over the sine graph not integrate or
pile onto okay
so instead of starting here I started 90
degrees forward okay so I'm starting up
here that's why I put a mark in there
and I'm gonna go down and then I'm gonna
reach this bottom part I guess you could
call it the bottom of the valley I'm
going to reach it earlier then I reached
it before instead of 270 I'm going to
meet at 90 degrees earlier at 180 that's
why my spot is there and that's why this
spot is here okay
many of you we're seeing our drawing
with pen it's not a bad idea to
eventually draw impaired it does come up
easier to read scanning all the rest in
the HSC but I can't recommend strongly
enough that you draw your first graph in
pencil in something you can erase okay
oh by the way I didn't know this before
who's got an erasable pen does they
don't have any of those okay all right
it's fine I didn't know this before but
I'm just going to put a word of warning
out there because some of you like I
know how to do pen but also have it a
raisable didn't realize this before but
those are raisable pen ink things
they're not as durable as normal pick
which shouldn't surprise us because
they're a reasonable after all but I've
heard stories of people who've left
their book in the car it's been hot and
they come back and it's like what
happened to oh my aching is just gone
and other things so just be watchful now
I know my points okay so now I'm going
to do one more thing
and if you want haven't done your cosign
right I've put in these three horizontal
lines can anyone tell me why I've done
that three horizontal lines there are
two reasons number one say it again one
yep okay I'm I know I'm supposed to get
stationary points there
secondly it's to avoid me doing this to
myself see this often you kind of like
drawing to a point you know you're
supposed to get there and then you're
like oh shoot I'm like too close and
then it ends up point here okay so now
that I've got these horizontal spots I
can quite easily in one line connect
that like so and then I can do the other
one in much the same way and now I'm
pretty happy we've been right so did you
notice the way I did it by the way I did
this half and then I did the other one
and your hand will find one way easier
to do than the other so do whichever
okay I'll put the labeling on that
afterwards but let's quickly have a look
at the tan one together what's the
definition for tan what is tan actually
equal to because like everything else
it's an abbreviation I'll give you a
clue it's an abbreviation of a ratio
it's sign of a cause isn't a very good
sign over cause now we've got the sign
on the cause graphs right here and
hopefully you've drawn them like some of
vertically on each other like I have
okay now what that means is have a look
here see this denominator cause X right
when we thought about domain earlier in
the year we remembered that I hope when
you're looking at a function which has a
fraction in it like this okay your
denominator is not ever allowed to be
zero why not because then you divide by
zero and the universe explodes right now
cause X look closely when is cos x equal
to zero you can tell me the values now I
haven't labeled them hopefully you've
labeled them here's cos x here's one he
is negative one
at what point along the graph does the
COS X hit zero 90 and 270 can you tell
me them in radians as well PI on two and
three PI on to I'm gonna keep pushing on
you because you've got to get more used
to doing this Iranian okay